Herkese
merhaba 22 yıldır hikayeler anlatıyorum
insanların hikayelerini ve habercilik
yapıyorum haberciliğin boyunca hiçbir
zaman ünlülerin ve
abone ol
bu haberciliğin boyunca hiçbir zaman
ünlülerin ve siyasilerin hikayelerini
anlatmayı sevmedim biz onlara
gazetecilikte söylem üstünleri diyoruz
Onlar zaten mesajlarını bir şekilde
ulaştırıyor lar Ben daha çok sizlerin
sıradan insanların sıradışı
hikayelerinin peşindeyim yüzlerce
hikayeyi anlattım sizin hikayelerinizi
bu sefer farklı birşey yapacağız ve
sizlere kendi hikayemi paylaşacağım
sizin de annemle babam bırakın Kerkük
kentinde doğdular Biz eğitimlerin orada
tamamladıktan sonra buraya İstanbul'a
üniversite okumaya geldiler Annem tıp
fakültesine babam Mühendislik o kumaşa
Mimarlık okumak için teknik üniversiteye
girdi öğrenciyken tanıştılar Aşık
oldular ve
ve okullarını bitirdikten sonra
evleneceğiz diye karar aldılar büyük
hayalleri vardı
ama gerçekten de hayalini kurdukları
gibi
o ilk önce ülkelerine döndüler ve kısa
bir süre sonra evlendiler tayinleri
ırakın kuzeyindeki Doğu kentine çıkmıştı
Ben ailenin birinci çocuğu olarak
1977'de Irakta dünyaya geldim Irak bugün
sizlerin bildiğiniz in aksine çok güzel
ve eğlenceli bir yerde çocukluk
yıllarına dair O anılarında
Bahçeli büyük evlerde aileler bir araya
gelir hoşça vakit geçirirdik
bu ülke Aslında çok renkli bir dini ve
etnik yapıya sahipti ve bizim o zamanlar
sünni-şii ayrımı bir yana Dursun bizim
evin içerisinde Ailemizin bir parçası
haline gelen Tadımız ummat Hristiyan
kapı komşumuz geziydi annemin hemşiresi
Kürt okuldaki öğretmenlerimiz arattı
ülkenin farklı bölgelerine geziler
düzenler dik ve bağdat'taki Beş Yıldızlı
otellerde harika tatiller yapardık Hatta
o dönem Fransa'nın başkenti Paris'e
ailece iki hafta bir seyahat yapma
şansımız bile olmuştur her şey böyle
güzel gidecek sanıyordu ve
1980'de iran-ırak Savaşı patlak verince
ülkedeki durum Her geçen gün daha da
kötüleşti bu ilk önce tabi yurt dışına
bütün çıkışlar yasaklandı ülkedeki Bütün
erkekler bir şekilde silah altına
alınıyordu şiddet günlük yaşantımızın
bir parçası haline gelmiştir
O bizim Tabi o güzel günlerimiz ile
ilgili bütün alanlarımızın devamındaki
süreçte
1984'te babam Erbil Belediye Başkanı
olmuştu ve ben
Ben ailemle birlikte Tabii ki eğer bile
taşındık dünyanın heryerinde çocuklar
Sabahları çalar saatle güne başlarlar
değil mi bizimde bizse güne İran
uçaklarının
bu ülkeye girdiğini duyuran prenseslerin
sesleriyle yataklarımız dan sıçradı ilk
önce 3 dakikalık böyle dalgalı bir siren
sesi duyarsınız bu hava saldırısı
anlamına gelir gökyüzünü yararcasına
patlama sesleriyle yataklarımız da
sıçrar paldır küldür Merdivenlerden
aşağı sığınaklara iner dik bu
Bu fotoğraftaki Benim babamın
korumalarından biriydi
Ama babam bir yere gittiğimizde Babamla
birlikte
korumalardan izinli olanın silahını Bana
verirlerdi tüfeğini tutmayı çok severdim
şarjörü boş olsa da babam bu durumdan
hiç hoşlanmaz the Çünkü o Beş çocuğu
vardı ve dördü erkekti hislerinde Bu
anlamsız şiddet girdi bunun ve savaşın
bir parçası olmamızı asla istemiyordu
Irak'ta baas rejimi oradaki Türklere
yönelik çok büyük baskılar uyguluyordu
Babam belediye başkanlığı gibi önemli
bir göreve gelmiş olmasına rağmen hiçbir
zaman bazı Partisi'ne üye olmadı Annem
de öyle Bu cinayet ve suç grubunun
yaptığı günahlara onların işlediği
suçların bir parçası olmak
istemiyorlardı Avis çocukların daha bunu
bu dirilişine kadar devam ettireceğiz
konusunda hiçbir fikrimiz yoktu çünkü
bazı Partisi daha çocukluk yaşlarımız
dan itibaren hayatımıza
abone ol bir İzci kamplarındaki
Propaganda çalışmaları daha ilerki
yıllarda
Bizlerin bu Saddam'ın Fedaileri olarak
bildiğimiz eğitim kamplarındaki silahlı
eğitimlere dönüşüyordu
Ya bırak bırak da
bu vurulmuş sokakta yerde cansız yatan
bir insanı gördüğümde henüz dokuz
yaşındaydım ve bu şiddetle yorulmuş
ülkede gerçekten tünelin sonunda bir
ışık görünmüyordu O benim bir gün
kardeşimle evin içerisinde annemin
sakladı çikolataları arıyorduk
çikolatayı Hazineyi annemin dolabında
bulduk o sırada annemle babamın içeri
geldiğini fark ettik ve kendimizi
dolabın içine atıp kapakların üstümüze
kapattı Annemle babam kısık bir sesle
çok hararetli bir konuyu tartışıyorlardı
ama onları hala çok net bir şekilde
duyabiliyordum Bizimkiler
bu yasa dışı yollarla Iran dışına
kaçmayı planlıyorlar the bunu Duyar
duymaz istem dışı bir hareketle elimde
ağzını kapattım hatırlıyorum Çünkü daha
o yaşta ülke dışına kaçak bir şekilde
çıkmanın cezasının idam olduğunu çok iyi
biliyordu Ve annemle babamı bir daha
görmem görmek için bunun başkası
tarafından duyulmaması gerekiyordu
ve bu sürü Kardeşimle birlikte
kalacağımız güne kadar sakladık anneme
bunu duyduğumu hiç söylemedin bile
kerkük'ü en son gittiğimizde orada
akrabalarımızla Ve tanıdıklarınıza tabii
ki açacağımız onlara söylemeden son bir
kez vedalaştık onlarla helalleşti
Sabahın ilk ışıklarıyla yola koyulduğu
Muzda doğduğum şehre son bir kez baktım
bu akrabalarımı arkadaşlarımı tanıdığım
herkes öğretmenleri okulumu ve çocukluk
aşkımı Belki bir daha hiç görmeyecek bu
10 yaşındaki kalbime çok ağır bir yük
Tüh arabada annemin arkasında
oturuyordum ve dikiz aynasından Babam
beni görmesin diye yani oturdum koltuğa
iyice gömdüm dakikalarca hıçkıra hıçkıra
ağladım ta ki hiçbir şey hissetmeye ne
kadar
bu Sabahın ilk saatlerinde bir Okullar
açılmadan bir gün önceydi Bir Eylül
sabahı Türkiye sınırına Doğru yol
alıyorduk
Allah bizlere kendimize pikniğe gidiyor
muyuz süsü verdik yanımıza tencere
tabağı tabak işte örtü gibi şeyler
almıştık arabayla bize söylenen yere
ulaştık Kapıyı açıp açık araziye doğru
yürümeye derken koşmaya başladı hemen
tepemizde Irak sınır güçlerine ait bir
karakol vardı ve askerlerin bizi görmesi
işten bile değildi bir an önce açık
araziden kurtulup ağaçlarla kaplı vadiye
inmemiz gerekiyordu ama kalbim şimdi
olduğu gibi böyle küt küt atıyordu
askerler ya biz Ateş açsaydı bıçağı çok
korkmuştum ve Göğsümden fırlar casına
hızlı çarpan kalbin kontrol edemiyordum
Nihayet ağaçların gölgesinde
ulaştığımızda çok sakin iki Kaçakçı bizi
karşıladı yanlarında 3D katır vardı ben
ve kardeşim katılardan birincisine
Annemle kız kardeşim ikinci katıra Babam
ve en küçük iki kardeşim de üçüncü
katılabilirler çocuklar düşmesin diye
annem ve bu Bu kalıplar Onları
orada bu hatırlar gideceği yolu bilir
deyip de bizi öyle katırlarla da yola
saldılar başımıza hiç kimse olmadan zat
nehrinin Kayalık dağların arasından
yararak çıkarttığı o Sarp arazi boyunca
uzanan patikada Arar ilerlemeye başladık
o dakikadan sonra işimiz katılarak
almıştır Neyse ki katırlar bizleri Sağ
Salim varacağımız ilk buluşma noktasına
ulaştırdı orada bizi başka kaçakçılar
karşıladı önümüzde artık üç gün üç gece
sürecek Uzun bir yolculuk vardı bu
yürüdüğümüz o dağlık bölge bu günlerde
PKK terör örgütünün saklandığı Ve
bizlerin Zap kampı olarak bildiğimiz
vadinin Ta kendisiydi Biraz sonra tabi
yolculuk bitimine doğru karşımıza
üzerinde TC yazan beyaz sınır taşı geldi
ve o noktadan sonra artık Türkiye dedik
bu noktadan itibaren de bizler resmen
mülteci olmuştu
Sen yabancı bir ülkede Yeni bir hayata
başlamak gerçekten çok zor bir iş Allah
kimseye göstermesin yaşatmasın Bizler
Ben de kardeşim ana dilimiz Türkçe
olmasına rağmen o yaşımıza kadar Arapça
eğitim görmüştük ve okul hayatına
intibak etmemiz kendimizi toparlama mız
bayağı zamanımızı ve emeğimizi aldı
Annemle babam emekli Yemişken onlar da
emeklilerini ve emekliliklerini yakarak
yeni bir ülkede kırk yaşından sonra Beş
çocukla sıfırdan bir yaşam kuracaklar
the gerçekten de maddi ve manevi olarak
çok yıpratıcı bir süreç de bu Biz
yaralarımızı sarıp yeni bir ülkede yeni
bir yaşama ayak uydurmaya çalışırken
1990'da
ve Göçe zorlanan Bulgaristan Türkleri
1991'de ıraktan gelen birinci Körfez
nedeniyle gelen
göçmenler 1992'de de Bosna'da üç yıl
süren savaşın mağdurları Tıpkı bizim
gibi Türkiye'ye sığındılar
bu savaşın acılarını yaşayan
tanıdıklarımızı hikayelerini bir türlü
medyada görmüyorduk kaçıp batılı Medya
Irak'ta olup bitenleri hem taraflı hem
de manipülatif bir yaklaşım sergiliyordu
oradaki konuları olayları takip eden
Türk medyası ise Bunu daha çok yabancı
ajansların haberleri üzerinden yaptığı
için olup biteni tam olarak Türk
izleyicisine okuyucusunu aktarılmıyor du
bunu net bir şekilde gördüğüm için
gazeteci olmaya karar verdim İstanbul
Üniversitesi Gazetecilik bölümünü
okuduktan sonra mesleğe Türkiye'nin ilk
Haber Özel haber kanalı o lanet evde
başladım
1999'da hayalim doğduğum ülkeye gazeteci
olarak dönmekti Ama bunu yapman pek
mümkün değildir Çünkü bazı rejim hala
yönetimdeki ve işin ucunda idam vardı
Nihayet dokuz Nisan 2003'te Saddam
rejimi devrilince hemen soluğu da aldım
Hayalimdeki o güzel anıların Peşine
Düştü Sen de ırak çok değişmişti ve
köprünün altından çok sular akmıştı
mı bıraktılar da saddam'dan sonra daha
güzel bir hayat umuyordu benim
çocukluğumdaki o hatıraların yaşandı
güzel dönemlere gideceğimizi
sanıyorduk büyük bir çoğunluk ama aradan
geçen yıllar içerisinde bunun mümkün
olmayacağı ırağın çok kanlı bir etnik ve
mezhepsel çatışmanın içine düştüğünü
görecektik ülkeye Tıpkı freni patlamış
bir kamyon gibi uçurumun eşiğine doğru
gidiyordu
2004-2008 yılları arasındaki o zor
dönemlerde bırakta gazeteciydi daha
sonra bu freni patlayan kamyon Suriye'ye
girdi 2011'de Suriye'de halk daha fazla
özgürlük taleplerini sokağa döküldüler
Beşşar Esed yönetiminin buna yanıtı ysa
silahla oldu E tabi O zamandan bugüne
kanlı bir iç savaş var ve binlerce insan
bu savaşlarda yaşamını yitirdiği
yitirmeye devam ediyor dahası ıraktaki
El Kaide Suriye'ye geçti ve orada Daş
terör örgütünü kurarak hem bölgede hem
de dünyada şiddeti bambaşka bir boyuta
taşıdı
bu 2004'ten beri şiddetin savaşın ve
yıkımın haberlerini yapıyorum halkanın
hikayesi bunlardan yalnızca bir tanesi
Ama beni çok etkiledi ve belki de bugün
bu konuşmayı halka için yapıyorum o
halka
12000 49 yılında ırak ın Musul kentine
bağlı Sincar kasabasında yezid'i bir
ailede dünyaya gözlerini açtı ve
Mezopotamya uygarlığının kendine özgü
kültürel ve dini öğelerine sahip
topluluk topluluğu olan Yezidiler veya
Ezidiler aslında kendi toplulukları
dışında kimseyle de pek evlenmezler
yasaktır topluluk duş evlilik bu
görüntüler halkanın köyünde bir düğün
sırasında çekilmiştir
bu halkar burada daha 2 yaşında bile
değildi mütevazi basit ama mutlu bir
yaşantıları vardı Ağustos 2014'te dar
Suriye'den topladığı güçlerle sincar'a
girdiğinde halkar ve ailesi için kabusun
başlangıcıydı halkar o tarihten sonra
babasını bir daha hiç görmedi ona ne
olduğunu hala bilmiyorlar halkanın
annesi ve kat diğer kardeşleriyle
birlikte Daş aile esir aldı ve Suriye'ye
götürdü halkanın annesi 1-2 ya satıldı O
da bir başkasına O da bir üçüncüsü ne
sattı onlara beş yıl boyunca kadıncağız
çocuklarıyla birlikte o adamla yaşamak
zorunda kaldı
o halka sekiz yaşındayken annesinden
koparılıp daha şın eğitim kamplarına
gönderildi orada silah ve doktrin
eğitimine tâbi tutuldu tabanca
kullanmayı tüfek kullanmayı Öğrettiler
küçücük bir çocuğa ismini Abdullah diye
değiştirdiler
bu Suriye'de Daş yeniliği askeri olarak
yenilgiye uğratıldı ktan sonra halkanın
annesi ve 3 Kardeşi için tutsaklık sona
ermişti onları ırağa geri gönderdiler
ama halkalardan Hala haber yoktu ama ki
Suriyeli yerel bir kanal halklarla bu
röportajı yapana kadar Amcası onu görür
görmez heryerden onun kurtarılması için
yardım istedi bu çağrıya Türk Dışişleri
yanıtsız bırakmadı bu çağrıyı ve Türk
istihbaratının düzenlediği operasyona
halkar Suriye'den alınıp Hatay'a
getirildi halkalarla orada tanıştım 310
yaşındaydı benim Irak'ı terk ettiğim yaş
bu geldiğimiz bölge yaşadığımız hikaye
bambaşka olsa da yaşadığımız trama
ürkütücü bir şekilde birbirine
benziyordu
Biz birbirimizi çok iyi anlıyor duk
belki de o yüzden beni çok sevdi
Hatay'dan uçakla önce İstanbul'a sonra
da Erbil'e geçtik Erbil'de ertesi gün
iki saatlik bir kara yolculuğuyla
halkanın ailesinin yaşadığı
alttaki bir mülteci kampına mı
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
hı
hangisini
[Müzik]
youtuberları
yazarım
çıkıklara hızlıları
ve bu halkanın ailesi ve 5 yıldır
görmediği akrabalariyla ilk buluşması
ydı bir yabancı gibiydi Sanki annesine
değil de bir yabancıya sarılıyor gibiydi
ama gerçekten de çocuğu biraz
gözlemledim Bana sanki da haşlı
abdullah'la yezid'i halk arasında gidip
geliyordu Hatta daha çok Abdullah
olmuştu annesini başörtüsü takması için
zorluyordu baş açık gezmesine kızıyordu
bizim Annesini o şekilde çekmemize İzin
vermiyordu bize engellemeye çalışıyordu
araya ufak bir bilgi sıkıştırmak
istiyorum da Haçlılar birbirlerine
seslenirken Arapça ahiyan-i kardeşim
veya din kardeşim şeklinde seslenirler
bu PKK'lıların birbirlerine Heval dediği
gibi bir şey
bu derken bizim havasini bizim halka bir
sinir krizi geçirmeye ve annesini
vurmaya başladı dayanamadım müdahale
ettim çocuk kollarından tutup kenara
çektim halkar Anne ne böyle yapamazsın
dedim bir abi edasıyla gözlerimin içine
baktı dahi ben halk Benim adım halkar
değil Abdullah dedi
O çok şaşırmıştım Ama hemen bir şey
söylemem gerekiyordu İyi o zaman sana
Abdullah ismini verenler Kuranı Kerim'de
anne baba ya öf dahi demenin demen
gerektiğini yazdığını da öğretmiştir o
zaman sana dedim Bunu duyunca başını
önüne eğdi ve çadırın en uzak köşesine
öylece oturdum
ve bu hikaye böyle bitmemeliydi bu bir
umut hikayesi olmalıydı
Bu halk ara bu kadar yıldır da şu an
kulaklarına fısıldadığı na karşın
ailesiyle henüz birkaç saat geçirmişti
arkadaşlarıyla akrabalariyla çevresiyle
yeniden kaynaşması için ona biraz zaman
tanımamız belki de en doğrusu olacak
Temmuz 2017'de
ve Musul Daştan kurtarıldı hemen kente
gittim kentte başta Selçuklular
döneminde yapılan Ulu Cami başta olmak
üzere bütün eski Türk eserleri yerle bir
edilmişti inanılmaz bir yıkım vardı bu
yıkımın içerisinde tabi insanlar da
vardı öldürülen da haçlıların canlı
olarak kurtarılan çocukları özel bir
yetimhaneye alınmıştı bu yetimhanede
yüzlerini çekmemiz koşuluyla haber
yapmama İzin verdiler
ve bu yetimhanede Beni en çok etkileyen
yer bu bir yenidoğanların tutuldu bu o
da olmuştu sıfırla bir yaş arasındaki bu
çocuklar kızım da o zamanlar bu yaşlıydı
ellerine aldıkları Bir nesneyi sıkıca
tutacak motor becerilere sahip değiller
di Ama bu çocuklar hayatta kalma
içgüdüsü ile onlara verilen biberonları
elleri ve ayaklarıyla sımsıkı tutup
içindeki son damla süte kadar emiyorlar
the Bu çocukların sütten daha fazla
değer verdiği bir şey varsa o da
sevgiydi koca yatakhaneye bir kadın
bakıyordu Ve bu çocuklar onun dikkatini
çekip kucağında biraz sevilmek için
yapmadıkları sevimliliği bırakmıyorlar
the haberi çekerken Dayanamadım Bir iki
tanesini aldım kucağımda dakikalarca
sevdim minicik elleriyle yakamdan
parmağımdan Kulağımdan tutuyorlardı beni
bırakma dercesine Kim bilir bu masumları
benden sonra en son kim sevdi
Bu bir diğer derslikte daha büyük
yaştaki çocuklar vardı bir resim dersi
ydi kendimi kısaca tanıttıktan sonra hiç
ben yokmuşum gibi rahat bir şekilde
derslerine devam etmelerini rica ettim
biraz sonra en ön sıradaki bir kız
dikkatimi çekti
çizdikleri hepimizin çizdiği şeylerde
beyazbulut mavi gökyüzü yeşil çayırlar
değil mi birde pembe panjurlu ev bu
kızın resmini de onun yerine mavi
brandalı Bir Mülteci çadırı vardır Öyle
ya binlerce çocuk yıllardır devam eden
savaşlarda gözlerini mülteci
çadırlarında dünyaya açtılar
o mavi mülteci mavi brandalı bu mülteci
çadırını yuva bilen bu çocuklar Acaba
nasıl bir gelecek Hayal ediyordu
ya dedim ya halkar halka ile başlamıştı
Her şey 6 ay sonra Halkalı görmek için
yeniden onlara gittik kötü haber annesi
çocuklarını terk etmişti onu suçlamayın
lütfen onun da daha acıklı bir hikayesi
var Dolayısıyla onu suçlamayın hemen
çocuklara babaannesi ve amcaları
bakıyordu halk arsa iyi haber halkar
hayata tutunmuş yaralarını sarmaya
başlamıştı zamana ihtiyacı var Kendimden
biliyorum
bu düşünmeden edemiyorum acaba hayat
bana farklı bir yol çiz Seydi şimdi
nasıl bir dünya olacaktı Nasıl bir
hayatım olacaktı bu Muhtemelen
Türkiye'ye gelmeyi bırakta kalsaydım
Ortaokulu okurdum orada Saddam'ın
tedavileri kamplarına katılır eğitim
görürdüm
bu koalisyon güçleri bir köfte
Savaşı'ndaki bombardımanları sırasında
Eğer ölmeseydim Daha sonrasında lise ve
üniversite eğitimine devam ederdim Ya
annem gibi Doktor ya da babam gibi Mimar
olurdum Büyük olasılıkla bırak da
gazeteci olmamı düşünmüyorsunuz herhalde
var ama okul bittikten sonra bu sefer
zorunlu askerlik ve ikinci Körfez Savaşı
Allah bizi beni hangi cephe süreceklerdi
Oradan da canlı olarak kurtulma şansına
Nail olsaydım o zaman işte belki de
Saddam sonrası Irak ta yeni bir hayat
kurulacağı çocukluğumun o güzel
günlerine dönüleceğini umuduyla
Kerkük'te gider evlenir çoluğa çocuğa
karıştırdım aradan geçen Birkaç yıl
içerisinde
İşlerin hiç de düşündüğüm gibi
gitmeyeceğini anlamam uzun sürmeyecektir
bu işte o zaman ben de belki Tıpkı
babamın 35 yıl önce yaptığı gibi
çocuklarımın ve ailemin daha güvenli bir
ortamda yetişmesi için bıraktan
kaçacaktım 5'te o zaman karşınıza
gazeteci Can hasasu olarak değil
bu mülteci Can hastası olarak çıkacaktım
belki de
ve bu fotoğraf bin 900
bu 87d Türkiye'de çekildi İstanbul
Emniyeti'ndeki göç dosyamızı bu
fotoğrafı koydular fotoğrafın en sağında
duran çocuk benim
bu fotoğraf biraz suyu ama gözümüzdeki
korku ve gelecek endişesi çok net
Ama bu güzel ülkenin Siz özel insanları
bana ve aileme İkinci bir şans
tanıdığınız bu şans sayesinde ben bugün
karşınızda gazeteci Can hasasu olarak
duruyorum kardeşim makine mühendisi oldu
kız kardeşim doktor oldu annem gibi ve
bir yıldır diğer bütün sağlık
çalışanlarımız gibi komisyon mücadele
ediyor 4 numaramız Mimar oldu 5
numaramız da elektrik elektronik
mühendisi Bizim Hikayemiz bir istisna
değil Etrafınıza kendi hikayelerini Z
kendi ailelerinize bakarsanız
Balkanlardan kafkaslardan Azerbaycan'dan
Şam'dan girit'ten hepinizin gelmiş
dedesi bir tanıdığı bir bildiği vardır
muhtemelen sahibiz Orta Asya'dan
gelmişti değil mi o unutuyoruz bu
topraklar hepinize kucak açtı hepinize
İkinci bir şans verdi şimdi sizlerden
bütün siyasi kimliğin izden
düşüncelerinizden tuttuğunuz takımdan
Herşeyden sıyrılıp insan olarak sadece
insan olarak bu bilgileri dinlemenizi
can kulağıyla dinlemenizi rica ediyorum
10 yıldır komşumuz Suriye'de kanlı bir
iç savaş var ve bu kanlı Savaşın en
masum en hiçbir şeyle alakası olmayan
kurbanları çocuklar ve bu savaştan bu
savaş nedeniyle
3200000 Suriyeli çocuk içeride ve
dışarıda Okula gidemiyor cehalet en
tehlikeli şey 5 milyon çocuk savaşın
içerisinde doğdu bunların Bir Milyonu
mülteci olarak dünyaya gözlerini açtı
5700 çocuk PKK ve Daş başta olmak üzere
terör örgütlerinin saflarına çocuk
askerler olarak katıldılar
de bundan sonra saatinizi her
baktığınızda şimdi söyleyeceğim şey
hatırlayacağınız dan eminim Çünkü her
saat her On saatte bir Suriye'deki
şiddet nedeniyle bir çocuk yaşamını
yitiriyor
ama gerçekten de
bu savaş bütün haberciliğinin Önemli bir
kısmını aldı göğüslerdeki başka şeylerin
haberini yapıyordum ama bu bir
hayatımızın bir gerçeği bu fotoğrafı da
telaferli mültecilerin kaldığı bir
Kampta çektim bırakta
etraflarındaki bütün umutsuzluğa rağmen
gözleri umutla parlayan Bu çocukların bu
halini sonsuza kadar öylece dondurmak
istedi
bu sorduğunuzda Mimar Dr pilot hepsi bir
şey olmak istiyor gelecekte şu dünyadaki
hiçbir çocuk Ben büyüyünce terörist
olacağım demez dünyadaki hiçbir insan
Ben gelecek yaz Türkiye'ye mülteci
olarak gideceğim gibi bir hayal kurmaz
bu daha çok onların kulağına kimin Neyi
fısıldadığı na ellerinden kimi tutup
nereye götürdüğüne bağlı Sizler günlük
koşuşturma canınız içerisinde Tabii ki
ne hal karla tanışabilirsiniz ne
dedaş'ın yetim çocuklarıyla mülteci
kamplarında çocuk doğan çocukların
dramına tanıklık etmenizi kimse
bekleyemez
ya Ben bütün bu hikayeleri sizlere
getirmekle görevliyim Bu benim işim
Bugün de tam da işte bunu yaptım onları
Artık siz de tanıyorsunuz Ve
biliyorsunuz ki bu güzel çocukların bu
masum çocukların on yıl sonra karşınıza
nasıl çıkacağı bu konuşmadan sonra
yapacaklarınız a dahası
yapmayacaklarını za bağlı olacak
Teşekkür ederim ima